Is, it's almost like
communities, you know,
is is you have your, your, your thoughts.
I've got my thoughts and we're part
of two separate communities. Right.
And it's just like with anything else,
he,
I think that integration between the two
and that balance is like the most key
to everybody really. It kind of will
grow everybody, you know, the, the,
the bounty hunters can learn something
from the Vegan is just much the vegans
can learn from the bounty hunters, you
know what I'm saying? I think so too.
You know,
and I think that really the problem is
when people don't want to hear the other
side and they want to shout people down,
they don't,
they're not willing to listen.
And there's,
there's common ground across
the board and some of it,
it probably is just learned,
I think a lot about like how you grew up.
And I think it's important to
like understand that, like I said,
just to go back to my childhood,
it is just,
that's the way I grew up and
that's what I understood.
But when I look at like
my dad, you know, like my,
my dad didn't have his dad so,
and he was out the house by 15 you know,
he and I try and put myself
there sometimes being a 15
year old kid that didn't
have a place to go.
Like what are you going to do?
And the only people you see around you is,
is drug dealers and in and on us.
So like a lot of it I give credit to
him for sticking around for me because I
would have no people over top of the
head, you know? You know what I mean?
And that's why people do it because
those people that are doing that are just
like you and me.
Everybody's like you said,
we're all just human beings and
we very genetically and we vary,
but we very more buyer environment, how
much love we get. Yeah, yeah. That's it.
That's a big part of it is like
it's just the culture is, it's just,
you know,
and I think it stems from one culture
being separated from others and not having
that integration. Then you get that
like even more of a disconnect.
And then once you get the
even bigger than, you know,
it's, it's all like downhill,
more insecurity, which leads
to more tribalism and it's,
the whole thing is just,
it's so disappointing that
people still operate like this.
But I think people were opening
up to that more now than before.
I just think it's a slow process.
Slowly but surely,
slowly but surely we still working at it.
You know,
we were talking before about the
Rosa parks picture out there.
That wasn't that long ago, man. No,
no, no. It really wasn't. And, and,
and that'd be the thing with certain,
there's certain white people too
that just be like, all right,
just get over it already. And
it's like, come on, like it,
they didn't have to get over it. Exactly.
It is, they experience it then you don't,
you truly don't understand.
Uh,
and you don't even like take the time
to try and understand their tribal to,
they'd talked to other people that say
the same shit and like, yeah. Well,
and they'll just start rattling off the
statistics about the instances of crime
in the black community and how the
agents don't do this, but the blacks do.
It's like it's fucking cultural.
If you don't think it's cultural,
you haven't been enough around enough
people and it does not go back.
A lot of generations, like you said, the
course is not very long ago. You know,
my dad didn't have his dad,
he didn't have that person to teach him
what not to do and what to do. You know,
it's, it's, that's a, that's a, that's
a hard road, especially for a young,
like you go back earlier, like young
guys get delusional real quick, you know,
they feel invincible. He felt like, oh,
I can do this and I'm
never going to get caught.
You don't have that voice of reason
to tell you right from wrong when you,
when you that kind of age and it's
because he didn't have his dad.
And then while I didn't have his
dad because he didn't have his dad,
you know what I mean? That only
goes back two or three generations.
Crazy. As you're talking about
1865 is when slavery was abolished.
So we're talking about a small amount
of time in human history where there
haven't been slaved.
So all your isolation when you,
you felt as a kid where you felt separate
from the people that were in the miles
that were higher than yours.
Think about that.
Times a hundred is if you were a
slave and maybe a million remedial
insurmountable gap between a slave that
has no chance of ever not being a slave.
And someone who can go to school wherever
they want and travel abroad and do
whatever the fuck they want.
And then the idea that some of these white
people think that these people should
just get over it with the amount
of time is so fucking short.
You're talking about we just had
black panther, the lifestyle,
we just had it beat Avatar.
It's beating.
Yeah. I mean one of the number one
biggest movies of all time. Stupid big.
That should help,
believe it or not,
I really think it would help.
It was a beautiful movie and it
was a beautiful movie to describe.
Even like when you say 1865 I feel
like we so disconnected from even that,
and this is,
I've talked to a lot of people about this,
the difference between being called a
black American and African American.
You know, I don't, I hate being
called an African American. I just,
that's what everybody says. But we
know and it's just taped it to me. It,
it makes you seem, because you put
me in Francis' next to each other,
Frances and an African American, you
know what I mean? He's, he's from Africa.
He has ties to African. Who else is
in African-american? Elon Musk. Yeah.
I mean, yeah, really when you are ill,
but I think even more now it Kinda like,
I just, why can't we be, the black
comes in so many different shades,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
And as this African obviously,
yeah.
So maybe black Americans a
better way to put it. Yeah.
But Africans have ties to Africa, you know
what I'm saying? Like black Americans,
slavery, like we feel, I feel we
should have our ties in America.
Like I should be proud to just be
an American, not be called that
African American we call it, you
know. Well it's with every generation.
It's going to take a long time before we
just abandon all this nonsense and just
treat people based on who
they are as a human being.
But my grandparents came from Italy
and they were treated like dog shit.
And my grandfather always talked about
the racism that he encountered when he
came over from Italy to America.
And they didn't think of
Italians as white people.
Now they think of Italians
is white people. 100% yeah.
And the Mexicans are experiencing that.
Like, you know, if you're from Spain,
you're basically white.
Like nobody thinks of a guy
from Spain as being like,
you don't think of in the same way
you think of Mexicans, right? Yeah.
But one day all that shit will go away.
One day we'll get past this,
whether it's who knows how
many generations it will take.
But I think it's changing now because
of the Internet. I think there's, yeah,
there's,
there's definitely like more hate
groups that the consolidate and they get
together and they, they, they, you know,
they, they live in an echo chamber online.
They talk, you know, and
they agree with each other.
You see it on Twitter and
Twitter's trying to stop that.
And maybe that's misguided
because maybe it strengthens it,
but I think that ultimately is the
ability to exchange information.
Is it going to allow more and more
people to compare notes and, and,
and understand that there's no,
there's no benefit to describe or to,
to,
to thinking of people as being inferior
or superior or better or worse.
We're just all different, but we're
all human. We're all just humans
of all the same. I mean, really, you
see that when you, when you see people,
you know, you can really see
somebody that you really know him.
You really see him. He's like, yeah,
it is. We literally all the same,
but all different too, because that's one
of the beautiful things is that you do,
you see these little different
aspects of individual's personalities,
but to lump people in a group, Oh,
you know, you're a Chinese guy. Oh,
I know what the fuck you
are. You're this. Oh,
you're an African guy on know what
the fuck you are. You're this. No,
that's nonsense.
There's a broad spectrum in each and
every classification, but at the,
at the end of the day, we're all the
same thing because we're all just people.
Yeah. Waa. Waa. Waa. Hundred
percent. I mean, yeah,
it's just when you talk about
heaven, like pride in, in,
in it,
I feel like helps a little bit more of a,
if I identify with like as a black
American, you know, instead of,
instead of like an African American,
it's just, see what you're saying.
You know what I mean? I feel like
it's a little more, you know,
I just looked different, you know
what I mean? Like I bought my,
I'm more integrated and it would
give me more pride to beat it. Right.
You know what I'm saying?
And, and I think that steel,
you were obviously all the same in,
in there needs to be integration but
you still have to have some type of
identity. You know what I'm saying? I
know what you're saying. Yeah. I mean,
and I think that the movie in itself
did a good job. Uh, I don't know.
I just went back to black pot,
Black Panther.
I think it did a great job in
describing like the differences,
there are differences between the black
community at in the African and African
Community, you know what I mean?
Or African Africa itself in,
in it because you get that,
you get that like anger,
you know what I mean?
Like that's like the stereotype is
like the bite angry black man. Right.
But some of it stems from not no one
where you're from and not having that core
identity.
Right.
And I feel like we can just do that
again here in America as black America is
instead of Idaho.
Yeah.
I hope what represents is a,
it's a meter to register that
racism is dying. Yeah. And that,
that this is,
this is also people in,
there's a lot of like why people that
were going way out of their way to go see
it because they wanted to show
everybody that they're not racist.
But I think that's good
too. Yeah. Ultimately it's,
it's showing that this is something that
people recognize as a stupid problem
and we should get past it.
It took God damn long
enough. I mean, what,
we're probably going to be telling this
to our grandchildren and they're still
going to be experiencing some of it and
then there's going to be something new
comes out and you're like, God, daily,
we just now doing this. Like, you know,
that's the way it going to be. Uh, but
for me personally, you know, he's just,
because everybody, every kid wants
to be a sober here. I'm like, oh,
how are you doing? You know? So
it's just like a whole lot of them.
You can be half of the empire and be
blade. Yeah. A, yeah. I mean, yeah,
but blade was like a hit man.
You know what I mean?
It goes back to what you see
around me. If I only see the, the,
the drug dealers and the,
you know, in every, you know,
there was never a black superhero and it
was like, all right, well shit. All right,
we didn't go up there, Huh? Yeah. And it
portrayed us as scientists or, you know,
it was loud. I just, yeah,
white get over it guys. That doesn't
register for you. Cause they're all white.
Every fucking superhero. Batman, spider
man. Even the Hawk is white. Okay.
First. Yeah. And I mean, and I, and
I, I get it from a lot of it. I mean,
there's just, it's just
culture. You know what I mean?
And it's is not better or worse than
one thing or another. You know, there,
there's Hawaiian culture,
there's, there's, you know,
it's just culture and it just,
that needs to be celebrated too,
because the more you celebrate culture,
the more you can integrate between
all of them. Right. And then
there's the real problem with,
I don't want those cultures
to go away. Yeah. You know,
I was in Chinatown in Boston this weekend.
We went and ate dinner at two o'clock
in the morning is Chinese restaurant.
It's China town, right? Jamie,
that place was China town.
They got like fucking, uh, Alaskan
king crabs in a fish tank. Like,
how the fuck did you even get that here?
It's still alive.
All these fish on top of each other and
they pull the fish out of the tank and
cook it up for you. I mean, it's like
they barely speak English. I mean,
this is their culture and I want that to
still exist too. You know what I mean?
I just want them to be accepted
100%. I mean, and, and
that's the beauty about it.
Not think you need to keep that alive.
You know,
there's two different spectrums
to it. There's the, there's the,
the person that's just like, oh,
just go ahead and get over it. Right.
And there is a person that just like,
okay, what you don't even have, like,
they don't want even like,
uh,
like I did it or acknowledge your culture,
you know what I mean?
They just want to like just
shun it or just not, you know,
just put it into a closet somewhere
and you know that that's almost the,
it's the opposite. But it's just
as bad as needs to be though.
A buddy of mine who lives on
the big island about that,
he's a white guy and he lives in Hawaii
and he grew up in Hawaii and I said,
did you experience a lot of racism
against white people? He's like, no,
cause I'm not a fucking asshole. And I
said, that's what it is, right? He's like,
yeah man. He goes, you can't be a white
guy coming over here trying to push your,
uh, you know, mainland culture is like,
this is the fucking culture dude. He goes,
if you just accept the culture
the way it is out here, he goes,
they're not racist. Let's see if you can
get a good, you're gonna run into a few,
but for the most part
you're going to run into a few everywhere
you go. Because people were like,
you got to go back to it. Like people
are fucking idiots in every walks of it.
But for the most part is always
you're not as though you good. Right.
It's the same way across the board
and I've kind of realized that as I'm,
as I'm getting older, because
before I just thought, you know,
we just what we are. Right.
You know what I mean?
I've got family members that
only will ever see Detroit.
They will only ever see those same blocks.
They will only ever see the same people
and that's just what you think it is and
it's just like, oh, it's so
much now there's so much,
how much more and it's not that
different that you think is different.
It's, it's different. But you know what
I'm saying? It's not, it's not alien,
it's just, it's just, it's different.
It's just different. It's not better,
not worse.
One of the things that I really enjoyed
about traveling so much with the UFC.
As you got to see all these different
cultures and you got to see all these
different styles of life that
these people live in and you know,
you kind of like put it all together
and you, you, it just gives you,
I think this is one of the best things
about traveling is that it gives you this
more rounded perspective.
Like if you lived in Italy,
you'd be like one of these people, if this
is how they live, they live like this.
You know, if you lived in Dublin,
you'd be like this, this is,
this is their style of living.
Yeah.
And it's,
and it's important to acknowledge I
think all those different styles until,
you know, and, uh, of
living. Uh, and, and, and,
and I think if you really want to like
cure racism in American, all that,
and it's just being open about it
and just talking and, you know,
people understand that other
people's upbringing is,
and what they went through and what they
do because that makes you understand it
more if you try.
And just shun it away or just say if you
even bring up the word black or white
or anything like people get,
you know, you kind of see it.
Sometimes people get tense
and it's just like just, just,
just be honest about it and
just be open about it and,
and that will make it go away.
It's not, it's not, you know,
shun it and it'll go away.
Don't want to be uncomfortable. They don't
want to talk about uncomfortable shit.
So if something comes up that's a, well,
you know, as a black man you're like, oh,
here we go. Here we go. I didn't
do it. Okay. I never had a slave.
Okay. You know, and you're
like, oh, all right man.
You just super uncomfortable
with being uncovered.
Yeah. It's like a, what for you?
I think that makes you that more of
the ass hole there, you know, talking
to a human being. If you really want
to have a conversation with them,
you want to know their actual
experience. Yeah. You know?
And if their experience is as a Puerto
Rican that came from Puerto Rico,
that feels disc,
a lot of Puerto Ricans feel
super disconnected with
the United States because
they're not really United States citizens,
but they are, it's like a weird thing.
It's kind of like, it's not
really a state, but it's,
it's sorta protected by the United States.
And so they're disconnected and there's
like on the east coast growing up with
Puerto Ricans, there's a weird, they have
a weird alienation, you know, and that's,
uh, if you don't want to talk to them and
you don't want to hear about that from
them,
that's fine,
but you're just gonna miss out on
that part of what life is for them.
You're never going to get it.
Yeah.
And all the things that they bring to it
and you know, the food that they bring,
the onto different arts,
you know what I mean?
The different styles of fighting that
they bring, the different dances.
Like everything is about
the culture you're going to
miss if you trying to just,
you know,
shy away from it.
It's martial arts is a perfect example
of like all these different cultures
coming together, and there's
one boiling pot, you know?
I mean, yeah, that's one of the most
beautiful things about it. It's just,
I can go over to Ireland and
fight or rush at in Ireland,
and it's different than going down
to Brazil then fight the Brazilian,
you know, or something
like that. It's just sure.
But it's at the core of it just still is
fighting. It's just different styles of,
of being able to do it.
But everybody does it.